[Musique]
durant les vacances scolaires Mascarin
jardin botanique de la Réunion propose
divers ateliers et animations pour les
enfants les M une saveur un atelier
ludique et convivial c'est un atelier
qui va avoir pour objectif de découvrir
un trésor donc on a caché sur le jardin
un trésor le trésor des saveurs et pour
le retrouver et bien il va falloir
retrouver
la la phrase clé permettant d'accéder au
trésor et pour ça va falloir suivre le
parcours des saveurs donc découvrir
l'acidité du kombava le corsé du du du
café Bourbon Pointu le sucré des dattes
le salé de la saliette voilà plusieurs
saveurs plusieurs plantes à découvrir
sur le jardin pour trouver le trésor des
saveurs voilà donc je suis venu avec un
groupe de 16 jeunes pour le faire
découvrir de manière ludique le jardin
botanique des mascaras donc voilà donc
c'est aussi dans un projet de
d'embellissement du du lieu où où ils
sont accueillis donc c'était un petit
peu la poursuite un petit peu de de tout
ça donc pour cette nouvelle année 2017
toutes les animations tourneront autour
des saveurs un nouveau programme
intitulé jardin d'essens on va avoir
donc à la fois des animations comme par
exemple animation des 1 une saveurs on
va aussi avoir des visites guidées une
visit guidé spécial qu'on a appelé le
parcours des saveurs qui a lieu à 14h
donc pendant les période de vacances et
il y a également un parcours en
autonomie qui est proposé justement
toujours sur le thème des saveurs donc
découvrir quelques plantes
traditionnelles quelques saveurs
traditionnelles de lîle découvrir enfin
à quoi ressemble la plante en question
donc tout ça est à découvrir ici à
Mascarin jardin botanique de la
[Musique]
Réunion